Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Mustafa Çelik.
Ich bin hier auf der Station Assistenz Arstetik.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese Gespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verhältnis?
Ja, gerne.
Okay. Kurzum Ablauf.
Ich werde Ihnen zuerst eine Parallelgemeine fragen stellen.
Und dann werden wir über Ihre Aktuelle Becherven sprechen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie werden erst mal.
Ich werde erst mal ein paar gemeine Fragen stellen.
Ich habe mal kurz gehört. Okay.
Okay.
Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid.
Oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Franz Beckenbauer.
Franz?
Beckenbauer.
Beckenbauer. Ja.
Am Ende Ihrer Vornahme ist Z.
Z Jawohl.
Ja. Franz Beckenbauer. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Beckenbauer?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
30, okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin am 5.03.1993 geboren.
5. März.
Okay. 19... 100, 93.
90. Ja. Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Beckenbauer?
Ich bin 1,85 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
90 kg. Okay. 90.
Okay. Ja. Was kann ich für Sie tun, Herr Beckenbauer?
Heute beim Fußballtraining.
Ja.
Ich habe mich mit meinen Spumgelenk umgeknickt.
Und habe seitdem starker Schmerzen und Schwellung
in meinem Außenknischelbereich.
Wann war dieser Unfall passiert?
Für ungefähr 4 Stunden heute.
4 Stunden.
Okay.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Ich habe Schmerzen in einer anderen Körperregion aus.
Nee, das ist nur im Spumgelenkbereich.
Das geschwollene Spumgelenk jetzt, ja.
Auch, ja.
Mein Außenknischel ist stark geschwollene.
Schwollene?
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten bei der Bewegung der Gelenkst,
glaube ich, hier?
Ja, ich möchte beim Laufen, auch bei Belastung,
bei Bewegung ohne Belastung habe ich auch Bewegungseinschränkung
und Schmerz, aber bei Belastung habe ich stärkere Schmerzen.
Ich kann nicht richtig auftreten.
Ich kann auftreten, aber es ist total stark weh.
Okay.
Auftreten können Sie nicht.
Ja, durch auftreten geht es schon, aber starken Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl oder Krippen bei der Gelenk- oder Fuß?
Im Gelenk, nee, habe ich keine Formatik.
Welche Seite habe ich nie geschrieben?
Das ist die rechte Seite.
Können Sie mir schreiben, die Charakter von Schmerzen,
das ist wichtig für uns.
Ich meine, sind der Schmerzen eher dumpf oder stehend
oder klopend?
Die Schmerzen sind pochend.
Pochend, ja.
Also ob ich manchmal ein zweites Herz am Sprunggelenk habe.
Ja.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Sie haben schon erzählt, eigentlich...
Also bei Fußfallspielen, die bestimmt aus ist,
das war jetzt kein Unfall mit jemand anderem,
sondern ich bin einfach mit meinem Sprunggelenk
und mit meinem Fuß umgeknüpft.
Gibt es andere Verletzungen auf dem Haut, meine ich?
An der Haut? Nee, gibt es nicht.
Also äußerlich sieht man nur, dass es stark geschwollen ist.
Haben Sie irgendeine Persian Medikamente dagegen eingenommen?
Ich meine, die Gurke verhören aus der Linie oder...?
Ja, wir haben nur gekühlt bis jetzt.
Keine Medikamente nur gekühlt, okay.
Erst vier Stunden her, ich weiß nicht, wo ich Medikamente bekommen könnte.
Wir sind vom Fußballspiel, vom Turnier hergekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon einmal sehr Verletzungen haben?
Ist diese Verletzungen erst einmal, oder haben Sie schon in der Vergangenheit...
Ist es so oder ähnlich?
Also ich habe mich öfter am Sprunggelenk umgeknickt, aber das war nie so stark geschwollen.
Okay.
Aber erstens ist nichts sehr schlimm, okay.
Ja, genau.
Also, das habe ich zum zwei, drei Mal, wo ich das umgeknickt habe, und das war schmerzhaft.
Aber das geht zum Arzt.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendeine Begleitende symptomatisch?
Ich meine, haben Sie Übelkeit, Erbrechen oder Verstopfung?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie... leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Blutdruck oder Hochbluthochdruck oder Rückerkrankheit oder Schädelstürmung?
Nein, nicht das ich höchste.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, das war 2005, wo ich einen Blind am operieren.
Blind am, okay.
Aber es war zwölf Jahre alt ungefähr.
Gab es keine Komplikation oder gab es keine Probleme bei der Operation, glaube ich?
Während der Operation direkt nicht mit der Operation, sondern man hat mir Antibiotika gegeben,
und das hätte ich nicht gut vertragen, sagen meine Eltern.
Hätte ich eine Art der Aktion gehabt.
Okay.
Welche Medikamente?
Ja.
Das ist wichtig.
Was?
Penicillin war das.
Ja.
Wir sagen, Sie haben einen Penicillin, Allergie, Penicillin.
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverträchlichkeiten?
Unverträchlichkeiten jetzt nicht, aber ich habe noch Nüsse und Gräserallergie.
Aber auch Nüsse ist mir nicht bekannt.
Nüsse und, das verstehe ich nicht irgendwie.
Ah, Gräser.
Gräser, ja.
Ein Grasmähergräser.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie Herr Beckenbauer?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Belegentlich, bei Feier nicht regelmäßig.
Okay.
Ich muss eine Routine fragen.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Nicht persönlich.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es Erkrankheiten oder Fälle von Krebs
oder irgendeine krönliche Krankheiten?
Familie, meinen Sie jetzt?
Wie weit?
Meine Eltern, Geschwister oder Sohn?
Kinder oder so.
Mein Vater leidet an Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Dann nimmt er Medikamente ein.
Wie die heißen, weiß ich nicht.
Mein Mutter leidet auch an Bluthochdruckerkrankungen,
Zuckererkrankungen und ist übergewichtig.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass Ihre Mutter viel Medikament eingenommen hat.
Ja, einiges.
Ja, okay.
Wie wichtig.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Mutter, aber der hat keine Krankheit,
der ist gesund.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Beckenbauer?
Ich bin Polizeibahmter.
Das ist gut.
Diese Fußballorganisation ist eine Hobbyzeit,
das ist nicht Arbeit.
Ja, ne, aber das ist ein kleiner Verein, also nicht das Profisinn.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin nicht verheiratet, ich bin ledig.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Hab ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Arbeit oder Social-Leben.
Ne, nicht besonders.
Das ist gut.
Ja, ich habe schon vergessen, sind Sie pochständig geimpft?
Herr Beckenbauer.
Ja, ich habe meine Tätonosen, die Kinderimpfungen habe ich alle.
Tätonos bin ich geimpft, auch gegen Covid bin ich geimpft.
Aber trotzdem war ich erkrankt vor halb Jahren.
Okay.
Das kann sein.
Ja, ist gut.
Tätonosen.
Okay, das war es, Herr Beckenbauer.
Ich habe alle die Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzugeben?
Ne, ich möchte nur hinzugeben, wie es weitergeht.
Was ich habe oder wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Der Ablauf.
Ich erkläre Ihnen, was ich machen soll.
Zuerst Sie sollen bei uns bleiben.
Machen wollen oder machen möchten?
Was ich machen soll, habe ich gesagt, machen möchten.
Was ich...
Okay.
Zuerst Sie sollen bei uns bleiben für weitere Untersuchungen.
Behandlung.
Nach meiner Meinung ist das eine Schuklungsgelenkprobleme.
Aber das ist sehr üblich.
Es gibt viele Falle im Unser Krankenhaus,
viele Patienten wie Sie.
Zuerst, ich meine, wir haben viele Erfahrungen damit.
Okay.
Wir werden eine Röntgenaufnahme machen,
Ihre Schuklungsgelenke.
Und dann, ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Und ich werde Ihre Vitalparameter beurteilen,
meine ich, die Ganzköpfertherapie,
und Blutdruck.
Und ich muss Ihre rechten Fußuntersuchung,
ich kontrolliere die Gefäß,
ob Ihre Sehkalt oder warm sind.
Und ich muss wieder untersuchen,
ob es eine Taubheits- oder Krippen gibt.
Ich muss darüber sicher sein, meine ich.
Und dann, ich werde Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Das zum ersten Mal, das ist der erste Schritt, meine ich.
Ja, das war es.
Okay.
Okay, das ist eine Frage.
Hab ich mit den Kollegen und Kollegen und der andere Frage.
Frage.
Okay.
Können Sie bitte den Fall genau beschreiben,
Ihre Fußaussehen umgeknüpft haben, Sie haben gesagt?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass mein Schwungelenk umgeknüpft ist.
Und am Außenknöchel ist es dick.
Außenknüchel.
Und wenn Sie die Richtung umgeknüpft haben,
außen oder innen?
Nach außen, überdreht.
Dankeschön.
Auf eine Wunde, keine, Sie haben gesagt.
Ja, genau.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie die Fußaussehen haben.
Ja, das ist pochend und pulsierend ist ähnlich.
Eine Rötung gibt es nicht.
Eine Schwellung gibt es ja.
Die Kollegen dürfen fragen, ich esse nicht.
Okay, keine.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja.
Mein Patient ist Franz Beckambauer.
Er ist 30 Jahre alt.
Am 5.3.1993 geboren.
Er ist 1 Meter, 85 groß.
Er ist 90 Kilogramm schwer.
Vor 4 Stunden hatte er einen Unfall bei Fußball.
Er hat ihr Sprung gerechnet.
Also ich höre nicht mehr.
Noch mal bitte wiederholen, weil der Internet etwas langsamer ist.
Er hat ihr Sprung gerechnet.
Umgeknickt.
Knicken.
Burgmark.
Umgeknickt.
Welche Sorte?
Rechte Seite hat er Probleme.
Er hat bei Belastung und Bewegung starkes Merzen.
Er hat eine geschwollene Gelenkbereich.
Er hat keine...
Könnten Sie fragen, wo genau dieser Schwellung ist?
Medial oder Lateral?
Schwellung?
Ja, habe ich nie gefragt.
Aber ich werde nacharbeiten.
Ich werde sehen.
Aber ich habe nie gefragt.
Ich habe...
Herr Kollege, können Sie die Frage wiederholen?
Ich...
Meine Frage?
Meine Frage ist...
Der Kollege hat gesagt,
dass er eine Schwellung im Sprunggelenk hat.
Und daraufhin fragte ich,
wo die Lokalisation der Schwellung wäre.
Herr Mustafa hat falsch verstanden.
Nein, nein, er hat verstanden.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
dass er im Außenberein...
Außenberein, aber ich habe...
Spinations- oder Pronation, Herr Kollege.
Welche Ambesten ist?
Nicht Ambesten ist, sondern welches wäre das Richtige?
Bei den Patienten, der hat gesagt,
dass er eine Überstreckungsform war.
Im Außenknechtelbereich.
Das heißt, was ist das?
Eine Spinationsform.
Spinationsform? Okay.
Danke schön.
Er hat keine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen.
Er hat nur gekühlt.
Aber es hat nicht geholfen.
Ja.
Und er würde 2005
einen Medikament verabschieden.
Und er hat keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Er hat Penicillinallergie
und Nussse- und Gräseallergie.
Wie äußern sich die Allergie?
Penicillinallergie, nachdem Penicillinallergie,
er hat Hautausschlag
und Madenprobleme gemacht.
Ja, so Matynicki.
Ja, ich bin da, ja.
Das heißt, ich bin da.
Okay.
Sie haben das nicht gefragt, deswegen frage ich das.
Ja.
Wer hat sich das,
hat Penicillinallergie,
hat sich mit Atemboot geäußert.
Und hat Penicillinallergie mit Hautausschlag abgehoben.
Okay.
Gut, weiter.
Ja, er saug nichts.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol und keine Drogen.
Nehmt es keine Drogen ein?
Ja, er nimmt keine Drogen ein.
Und meine Patientenpater,
der Vater von meiner Patientin hat Blutochdruck
und Mutter leiden an Diabetes-Medikamenten
und auch Blutochdruck.
Und die Beeltern nehmen Medikamente ein,
aber er weiß nicht, welche Medikamente sind.
Und er ist polizär beantah.
Er ist leidisch und hat keine Kinder,
polizär beantah.
Lebt er eine oder lebt er mit jemandem zusammen?
Ja, er ist Lady, aber habe ich nie gefragt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Er lebt mit einer Freundin zusammen.
Okay, weiter.
Ja, das war Anamnese.
Und als diagnostische Angabe würde ich eine Schuprunggelenk-Röntgenaufnahme
zwei Ebenen machen.
Erst mal Verdachtdiagnose.
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Schuprunggelenkdistortion.
Mit Schuprunggelenkdistortion ist ja eine feste Diagnose.
Aber was wäre der Verdacht, was dahinter steckt?
Was könnte sein?
Ja, es könnte sein auch.
Es kann ein Fibulafractor, vieler Fibulafractor.
Zum Beispiel?
Genau, das kann ein Fibulafractor.
Meins ist es,
dass es eine spezielle Fibulafractor,
eine istale Fibulafractor sein.
Okay, eine Faktor könnte es sein.
Eine Sehnenverletzung sein,
oder Riss von Sehnen sein.
Eine Sehnenverletzung sein, aber selten,
es ist ein Außenband-Ruptur,
weil es am Außenknüchen ist.
Es könnte auch eine freie Legamenten sein.
Ja, und es wird mehr nicht sein.
Im Außenknüchen gibt es auch nicht viel.
Es gibt entweder eine Fraktur oder ein Außenband-Riss.
Es gibt weitere Frakturen wie Thalus-Fraktur.
Man kann Theorien aufbauen.
Es fehlt mir nicht so viel ein.
Es kann auch ein Luxationstrauma sein.
Aber Haut und so weiter ist ein Takt.
Das heißt, so große Luxation.
Es ist bestimmt nicht gewesen, denke ich mir mal.
Okay, um diese Verdachtstiagnose zu erhärten.
Ja, für das Erhärten würde ich eine Röntgenaufnahme
des Schuh-Schum-Gellens durchspüren.
Ich wollte zwei Ebenen machen.
Die Röntgenaufnahme würde ich bei Ebenen anlassen.
Gegenüber jedenfalls werde ich ein MR,
Magnet-Resonanz,
einen gegebenen Fall,
einen MRT empfehlen.
Wenn es keine Fraktur sich darstellt,
würde ich das stabilisieren.
Ich würde das nicht empfehlen.
Ich würde das stabilisieren.
Ich würde es empfehlen.
Was würden Sie in einer Röntgenaufnahme sehen?
Was würden Sie ausschließen?
Wir können ein Fraktur ausschließen.
Mit Direkt-Graphie oder Röntgenaufnahme.
Wie ist es, wenn es eine Fraktur ist?
Sie haben vorhin eine Fibula Fraktur gesagt.
Wie ist es, wie man die einteilt?
Ich habe schon gelesen, aber ich erinnere mich nicht daran.
Es gibt ein Sosmos zwischen Tibia und Fibula.
Es gibt drei verschiedene Fraktur.
Es gibt ein Name von denen.
Weber.
Ein deutscher Name.
Es gibt Weber A, B und C Frakturen.
Die Brüche, die unterhalb der Synosmose sind,
sind A Frakturen.
Die Brüche, die auf der Höhe der Synosmose sind,
sind B Frakturen.
die Brüche, die oberhalb der Synthesnose sind, sind C-Frakturen.
Oberhalb, okay.
Und dann gibt es noch eine besondere Form, eine WBAC, eine hohe WBAC-Fraktur gibt es auch.
WBAC, aber?
WBAC gibt es aber auch eine hohe WBAC.
Ja, das heißt eine subkapitalen Fibula-Fraktur ist eine, bei einer Distorsionsraume eine
hohe WBAC-Fraktur.
Das heißt man muss das Kniegelenk mit untersuchen, ob das unterhalb des Kniegelenkes oder im Bereich
des Kniegelenkes auch Schmerzen sind sozusagen.
Da müsste man nicht nur eine Sprunggelenksaufnahme machen, sondern auch eine Sprunggelenk- und
Kniegelenksaufnahme mit Unterchenkel durchschüllen.
Aber zuerst müssen Sie ja den Patienten untersuchen und dann, also wie Sie vorangeben, vorhin
haben Sie das ein bisschen direkt mit Röntgen, Sie haben Verdachtstiagnose gesagt, dann direkt
Röntgen gesagt, ist eigentlich falsch, sondern erst sagt man die Verdachtstiagnose, eine
Arbeitshypothese, als zweitens würden Sie eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung
durchschüllen und dann würden Sie sagen, ah, um meine Verdachtstiagnose weiter zu
erhärteln und da aufzuschließen, möchte ich eine Sprunggelenksaufnahme machen sozusagen.
Ja, okay.
Sie meinen ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung allgemein, ja, das nicht nur beinahe.
Das ist für mich eine ausführliche und orthopedische Untersuchung.
Aber das ist beinahe.
Also zu einer speziellen Bereich, es geht ja nur um Sprunggelenk, ausführlich heißt
in dem Sinne, man will damit sagen, dass man richtig alle Möglichkeiten guckt,
was orthopedisch ist, was neurologisch grob orientiert ist, es ist kein neurologischer,
aber Sie können gucken, ob Taubheitsgefühl, Parasite, Sie können die Empfindungsstörungen
haben und so weiter, das ist halt der Spannung oder im Bereich der Spannung,
ob zum Beispiel ein Compartment-Syndrom entsteht und so weiter.
Und das dritte ist den Gefährstatus, zum Beispiel Tulsetasten, Atariya Dorsalis-Pedes,
zum Beispiel ob ein Durchsprung, oder ist es Levid oder nicht,
zum Beispiel Kälter als die kälter-zulinkenseite.
Und damit, es ist nicht definiert laut Gesetz,
was eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung ist, aber hört sich gut an.
Man kann sagen, ich mache eine körperliche Untersuchung,
dabei ist sowieso das alles drinnen.
Aber wenn man macht eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung,
hört sich gut an, plus man meint dann, ich denke auch dabei an neurologischen Status,
an Gefährstatus mit Syntosufen.
Okay?
Ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung heißt nicht, ob der gut atmen.
Der kommt ja mit Sprunggelenk, der ist 30 Jahre alt,
und der hat nicht gesagt, der ist jetzt ummächtig geworden und gefallen,
und deswegen hat er Sprunggelenk problemt, sondern er ist nicht gefallen,
der ist nur umgeknickt.
Da muss man nicht, Orthopäde, muss man jetzt da nicht ausführlich den ganzen Körper untersuchen,
ob der irgendwelche Einstichstellen hat oder irgendwas.
Ja, okay.
Vielen Dank.